the honeymoon is coming to an end for
President Obama president is losing his
popularity President Obama's honeymoon
ending the honeymoon may be over for
President Barack Obama the honeymoon is
over and it should be for Barack Obama
his policies have been genuinely
unpopular since before he was president
nobody liked tarp nobody liked the auto
bailout nobody likes the stimulus
package anymore once they realized that
it was gonna deliver very little except
massive budget deficits for the rest of
our life one of the reasons why
Americans have turned against Obama's
policies is that he's broken a series of
promises since he came into office well
he promised several times including late
in the campaign that he was going to
enact a net spending cut instead he has
gone on a spending rampage and he's
beginning to run out of other people's
money Obama's first budget was called a
new era of fiscal responsibility but all
it did was lay out a decade-long sea of
red ink that is gonna grow every year
and it's one of the reasons why his
credibility on everything is going down
the tubes and it's not just what he's
trying to do it's how he's trying to do
it in many ways Obama has picked up on
the worst traits of the presidency of
his predecessor George W Bush Bush
governed in an atmosphere of Perpetual
crisis Obama has used that same insight
and Americans are growing fatigue of
this policy by crisis mongering